Sherry the regular season is over the
Stanley Cup playoffs are back in Las
Vegas as the golden knights open first
round play tomorrow night ooh go Knights
go this is the fifth time in six years
the Vegas golden knights have made the
Stanley Cup Playoffs the fun starts
outside T-Mobile Arena fans can enjoy
pregame festivities outside Toshiba
Plaza before each playoff home game and
as you know Nate it gets loud out there
it sure does and I'm pretty sure that
the world's best corn dogs food truck
will be at the at the plaza let's go
yeah absolutely absolutely hey here's
the first round playoff schedule against
the Winnipeg Jets again game one
tomorrow night at The Fortress game two
Thursday night also at T-Mobile now
games three and four the series heads up
to Winnipeg John Heather wait we gotta
have John have a corn dog again because
you've only had one now okay if it means
I get to go to the game then I'm down
that's all that matters